my name is Nick Rennick I am a farmhand
an administrative assistant here at
McGrath brothers Great Pacific pumpkins
our pumpkins are shipped out all over
Southern California and they even make
their way into Nevada and Las Vegas and
we grow over a million pounds of
pumpkins every year it takes about four
to five months to finish the entire
process of the growth of the pumpkin we
start all the way back in March with the
ordering of the seed I can go all the
way into April before we get it ground
prep which means we take the big
tractors out and rip up the ground get
it ready to bed down starts in late
April throughout May we start to plant
the seeds at the end of May through June
all the way to the beginning of July for
the first two weeks we keep the
irrigation above-ground
threw sprinkler systems after that two
to two and a half week period we lay
drip tape down which is much more
efficient in terms of water use for the
rest of the pumpkins growth cycle it is
dead through drip irrigation all of its
nutrients including phosphorus and
nitrogen is pumped through the water
each one of these goldenrod flowers
produces a small bulb at the base of the
flower and each one of these flowers
eventually becomes a pumpkin every year
natural pollination is not quite enough
to provide all the plants with enough
pollination so we actually have to bring
in B boxes and we set them out around
the property and the bees do their thing
and without those bees we would not have
the pumpkins that you see today by the
beginning of September we need to cut
and roll our pumpkins into rows we need
to be able to get the large semi-trucks
into the field we have crews of 20 to 30
guys out in the field at a time going
one by one pumpkin by pumpkin and
picking every single one with the pair
of loppers that you'd use in your own
backyard cutting every pumpkin off the
vine if we have leftover pumpkins in a
given year we try and fulfill as many
donations to charitable causes as we can
and the remainder of them go to our
local Santa Barbara Zoo where they're
used to feed a variety of animals
almost all of them treat it as a
delightful autumn snack